an invisible danger hurtles towards
earth
at close to the speed of light
these are intergalactic alien
interlopers on our milky way
cosmic rays
getting hit by a cosmic ray is like
getting hit by a cosmic bullet
cosmic rays are billions of times more
energetic than any other types of
particles vastly more energetic than
anything we can even create in a
laboratory in a nuclear fusion reactor
anywhere
they pierce spaceships putting our
astronauts in danger
but the source of their power is a
mystery are they coming from other
galaxies are they coming from things in
between the galaxies where do cosmic
rays come from truth is the most
powerful ones we haven't got a clue the
race is on to solve the mystery of the
fastest particles in the universe
[Music]
[Music]
if i were to make a list of the dangers
of space it would be a long list you
know there's hard vacuum
huge swings in temperatures micro
meteorites all kinds of things
but probably at the very top of that
list
cosmic rays
these space invaders are not what they
seem
when you hear the name cosmic rays you
might think it's like a beam like a
laser beam of light no no no
it's a tiny little death particle
to fight them we must first understand
them
april 2019
nasa's parker probe flies closer to the
sun than ever before
we know the sun produces some of the
cosmic rays that fill the solar system
but we don't know how
our sun looks like
a beautiful
glowing orb bringing energy and light to
earth and allowing life to thrive
but if you look at it up close you'll
see a tumultuous storm of events
the amount of energy the sun is emitting
every second is the equivalent of 100
billion
one megaton bombs it's a dangerous
neighborhood
suddenly the probe is caught head-on in
a powerful blast
it's perfectly positioned to monitor the
outburst from the inside
the entire outer third of the sun is a
boiling cauldron and tied up in that
plasma or magnetic fields that get tied
and twisted and energy is stored in them
so they rise toward the surface and
there they rearrange they reconnect they
twist they spin
when the magnetic field lines snap
energy bursts
out and sometimes
that energy release is explosive and
that's what results in flares which are
these huge bursts of light
[Music]
the probe discovers that after a solar
flare the sun's surface stores
electrically charged particles
but sometimes there's a second explosion
called a coronal mass ejection
releasing superheated electrically
charged gas called plasma
these giant balls of plasma go flying
off the surface of the sun and in those
balls of plasma or contain these charged
particles the charged particles move
fast
but they hit a roadblock
a cloud of slower moving particles that
always surrounds the sun the solar wind
well the coronal mass ejection is moving
into the solar wind much faster than the
wind is moving so it sort of runs into
it and creates the shock wave and ends
up piling up particles at the edge
the shock wave and particles slam
together in the collision the particles
steal energy and speed like a baseball
accelerating off a bat
the particles transform into something
far more powerful
a solar cosmic ray
they're light but they're moving
incredibly fast
the earth is on average 93 million miles
away from the sun and these guys reach
us in about an hour that's 93 million
miles an hour that's pretty fast
the cosmic rays speed towards earth
we're under attack
cosmic rays
are by far the most energetic particles
that we know to exist in the universe
and when things with very high energy no
matter how small they are impact
something else they deposit that energy
right and so cosmic rays can be very
dangerous
solar cosmic rays aren't the only threat
we face
other space bullets arrive from beyond
our solar system
there are different kinds of cosmic rays
just like there are different kinds of
bullets
at the lowest end of the spectrum are
these solar cosmic rays
these are like the bbs and when a bb
hits you it might sting for a little bit
but you're not going to get too worried
about it a bigger concern
galactic cosmic rays they travel faster
and have more energy
if solar rays
are like bbs the galactic cosmic rays
are like rifle bullets
they're far more dangerous they're
moving a lot faster but they're also
more rare
faster still are the universe's most
wanted
ultra high energy cosmic rays
if you thought galactic cosmic rays were
bad is because you haven't met an ultra
high energy cosmic ray these are the
biggest
baddest
meanest cosmic rays in the universe
these ultra high energy cosmic rays are
like hypersonic missiles they are
screaming and they come from the most
energetic events in the universe
[Music]
the ultra-high-energy cosmic missiles
are the rarest but also the swiftest
these cosmic ray particles are moving
fast
these mysterious particles are moving
incredibly close to the speed of light
i'm not talking about 99 the speed of
light they're moving through space at
like 99.99999
21
that's fast that's wild that's scary
all three types of cosmic rays are
racing through the solar system
if i were to hold up a golf ball in the
middle of space
almost a hundred cosmic rays pass
through that golf ball every single
second
it's a deadly hail of particle bullets
and out in space our astronauts are
caught in the crossfire
cosmic rays represents one of the
greatest dangers for human spaceflight
nasa plans to send astronauts back to
the moon where radiation levels from
cosmic rays are 200 times greater than
on earth
and that is just the start one of nasa's
big goals is to send humans to mars and
that is a long way away at least a
six-month journey and more often about a
nine-month journey that's a big problem
i
am hoping that one day i can go to mars
as an astronaut but i'm definitely
afraid of cosmic rays and the more that
i read about it the bigger of a threat
it seems so
i think that nasa and other space
organizations are going to need to work
on how to protect their astronauts in
these really dangerous situations
only one group of people have been
exposed to these high levels of cosmic
rays
the crew members of the apollo missions
july 1969
one of the astronauts buzz aldrin
sees something strange
during apollo 11 buzz aldrin reported
seeing tiny little flashes sometimes
when he was looking around
that's pretty weird but what's weirder
is that he saw them when his eyes were
closed
later missions also report seeing odd
flashes of light
a streak in the lower left side of the
mustang moving
the astronauts describe the flashes as
spots
streaks and clouds apollo 15 commander
david scott reported seeing one that was
blue with a white cast like a blue
diamond
what's happening is that a cosmic ray is
entering the eyeball and then striking
molecules and giving off a flash of
light
an alternative theory is that it
triggers the layer
of sensitive cells
in your retina so you perceive a streak
of light even though no light ever
actually existed
the cosmic rays cause long-term damage
inside of the eyes lens there are these
fiber cells that are transparent well
when a cosmic ray travels through them
it can damage those cells and make them
cloudy causing cataracts when nasa
examines the astronauts helmets they
find tiny tracks etched through them
evidence of cosmic ray impacts
when we say that cosmic rays are like
tiny little bullets we're not joking
around
in some of these burrowed all the way
through the helmet which means
it ended up in the astronaut's brain
which just makes me feel weird to think
about
what might that long-term radiation do
to your brain to your ability to reason
and problem solve in one of the most
dangerous environments that humanity's
ever placed itself
the farther we venture from our home
planet
the more danger we face
[Music]
you